je ne vais pas sortir d'un gâteau mais
bon anniversaire Cyril tous les corps
s'associe à moi pour te souhaiter un
joyeux anniversaire on t'adore ne change
rien salut Baba je te souhaite un joyeux
anniversaire
profite bien de ta journée longue vie à
toi à plus
j'espère qu'on va continuer à performer
sur les terrains de paddle ensemble
éclate-toi bien sur ton émission allez
bises et beaucoup d'années qu'on se
connaît bon anniversaire qu'il bientôt
et enfin est-ce que tu vas répondre à ma
question combien tu vends ta voiture
Cyril je dis bien mon Cyril parce que tu
as toujours été là dans des moments
difficiles joyeux anniversaire à toi
je veux être un peu original et je pense
que je vais être la seule avec le
souhaiter sur une moto avec les
Champs-Élysées derrière allez bon
anniversaire
n'oublie pas les plus belles années
d'une vie sont celles qu'on a pas encore
vécu
j'adore
vous savez qu'il y avait il y avait
quand même il y avait quand même libre
non bah oui le numéro 1 mondial de
paddle il y a Michel Drucker M Pokora
merci mon frérot d'amour et Cauet alors
la voiture
frérot je sais que tu m'as envoyé des
messages pour la voiture je suis en
train de boire parce que je suis pas sûr
que je la vende je t'expliquerai pas à
vous cette belle voix dans la semaine
ouais pas moi mais je vends des choses à
des amis
vous pouvez la voir il se gare en bas
avec BFM il se gare il arrive toujours
devant il est arrivé il garde sa voiture
Maxime souhaite que je répète oui bah
c'est pas fini parce que là on a fait
une petite salle mais il y en a encore
une deuxième maintenant j'aimais bien
allez je vous laisse beaucoup appeler
toi arrête de sucer tout le monde mais
non mais je te dis il arrête
en train de boire un chocolat chaud
trouve-le à l'antenne voilà moi j'aime
arrêter
à chaque fois nous si jamais non hein
toi moi j'ai quoi
moi j'écoute la matière dans mon camion
je te dis moi j'écoute la matinale et
nous aime pas et souvent on prend des
bonnes perdus on a rien faire
ça arrête un peu c'est des mecs qui
veulent pas que j'aille les embrouiller
il se dit c'est un morba qui va pas nous
lâcher tu crois quoi ils ont préféré lui
dire allez c'est bon sinon il va venir
tous les jours là-bas nous mettre des
mollards allez on y va il y a kilos
mais c'est vrai
bon anniversaire et continue je sais que
c'est dur pour toi en ce moment les
audiences sont pas bonnes tu as pas
beaucoup d'argent mais ça ira tu verras
accroche-toi mon adresse mon petit Cyril
je te souhaite un joyeux anniversaire
je suis arrivé à Paris pour me lancer
dans ce métier le 23 septembre
1974 c'était un lundi voilà ça nous fait
un point commun de plus donc je te
souhaite un génial
continue de nous faire rire parce que tu
nous fais extrêmement rire voilà je
t'embrasse
tu sais c'est quoi l'anniversaire de
je tenais à te souhaiter un joyeux
anniversaire pour ton anniversaire si tu
veux on te prend ou pas d'elle quand tu
veux regarde allez bon courage je te dis
à bientôt
je te fais un gros bisou
franchement merci merci chérie parce que
qu'est-ce que je les aime là tous ah là
là avec mon gars d'amour Patrick Clara
il y avait la bande à physique qu'est-ce
que je les aime il y a Philippe Chérif
Philippe Lellouche il faut pas que j'en
oublie mais c'est vrai que je les ai je
les aime de ouf et merci Laurent aussi
franchement que j'aime voilà je vous dis
à tous ceux que vous m'avez mis là je
les aime il me manquait juste Maxime
sweat
on était au top je suis à de les appeler
en direct vous avez le numéro là
d'Apolline de Malherbe là je vais
l'appeler en direct sur la tête de ma
mère je vais l'appeler en direct
tant que j'aurai ça dans la tête je
pourrais pas faire cette émission
j'aurais rien à [ __ ]
[Applaudissements]
de la gueule encore combien de temps
mais sans déconner
son numéro en vélo moi ah c'est Stan
Wawrinka 2 minutes ouais mon frérot et
bravo joyeux anniversaire merci mon
frère dès que je suis à l'antenne là je
suis en train de faire l'émission ouais
mais bon tu avais des trucs secrets à me
dire
malheureusement mais bon il y a
peut-être trop de monde là en ce moment
voilà c'est pas le moment
tout à l'heure quand on sera que tous
les deux mon bébé
[Applaudissements]
hier à Metz il revient très fort mon
chéri et bon tu viens à la maison
allez je t'embrasse t'inquiète pas
t'inquiète pas gros bisous
c'est un ami qui vous est très cher je
trouve que vous avez écourté la
conversation
il m'est arrivé une darka immense je
vais vous la raconter j'ai plein de
joueurs de tennis qui dormaient chez moi
et le matin je vais prendre le petit déj
et je vois je suis en train de prendre
le piège et je vois une meuf arrivée je
suis dehors un peu comme ça dans un
petit un petit jardin
[Applaudissements]
et je vois arriver de pas loin
d'ailleurs
voilà de pas loin je vois avec quelqu'un
de pas loin des jumelles
[Rires]
je vois arriver une meuf qui s'assoit et
moi j'ai pas compris en fait parce qu'à
un moment j'ai cru que c'était ma meuf
parce que bah une meuf
voilà j'ai cru que c'était une meuf et
en fait une autre meuf des meufs comme
ça
il y avait des meufs que je connaissais
pas à la maison donc je commence à
prendre le petit déj avec elle
comment vous appelez vous êtes qui je
suis la meuf dans des joueurs et avril
petit déj ensemble mais à chaque fois je
vous dis il y a pas moyen il y a plein
de meufs qui arrivent comme ça